there's a lot of ways to make money in
America but I want to tell you about a
business model that's going to get you
to look at this in a completely
different way let's get right into it
think about this if you and I run a
hospital we got 200 beds if there's
empty beds you and I are not making
money so we need sick people to come to
the hospital to make money that's how we
make money if you and I own a hotel we
got 500 rooms guess what if our rooms
are empty we don't make any money we
need people to come and stay in our
hotel so we can make money right now
imagine a business model where you
needed more Wars for you to make more
money let me say that one more time
imagine an industry you're a part of
that you need more Wars potentially
people dying for you to make more money
that's like the Department of Defense
that's defense contractors the more
worse the more money you know how Papa
John says better ingredients better
Pizza Papa John's defense contractors
ready more Wars more people dying
defense contractors so so before I piss
some people off I'm Pro military I was
at the hunter first airborne and I love
the fact that U.S has got a strong
military but there's some people some
companies that are seeing it as a way of
making a ton of money and today we're
going to dive into different data that's
going to show to you where we compare to
other countries on how much money we're
spending and how much profits being made
so if you give value out of this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into it I've
been in the insurance industry for 23
years there's a product in the insurance
industry called life settlement so life
insurance companies when you buy product
they want you to either live a long life
because they're never going to have to
pay out the life insurance policy or
they want you to kind of cancel your
insurance policy 15 20 30 years later
right like you had a good age you're
healthy Council now they keep the money
you're good to go but there's a segment
of life insurance called life settlement
very profitable what life settlement
companies do is they go to an 80 year
old who's got a five million insurance
policy whose premium is going up and
it's like paying three four thousand
dollars a month who can't afford it
anymore and so I can't afford to pay 34
000 a month the lifestyle and Company
will say hey Mr Jones you got a five
million dollar insurance policy no
problem how about I give you one million
dollars cash up front I'll take over the
payments but when you die that death
benefit is coming to me that's called
the life settlement so now you may say
that's crazy wait a minute the 80 year
old is sitting there saying man that's
crazy I mean there's nobody else that
can pay this insurance policy too my
wife is dead or my husband's dead fine
I'll take the million dollars and you
can take the rest I'll give it over to
you fantastic that person got a million
dollars they're happy you're the person
about the policy you're not paying the
payment three four five thousand dollars
a month it's what you're doing every day
you're like did that guy die yet no
every day you're celebrating or waiting
for that person to die the sooner they
die the bigger rate of return you make
so it's a weird industry to be a part of
some call it Noble some have a hard time
selling this product but here's a moral
of the story you're incentivized to hope
for that client to die sooner rate of
return goes higher military industrial
complex defense contractors Boeing all
these Raytheon Northrop Grumman they all
make more money the more Wars they have
the more conflict there is the more
issues taking place they make more money
that's simply how it is now it's not
illegal nobody's doing anything illegal
but that's your business model having
said that I want to share a few things
with you okay so what the US Congress is
right now working on is a bipartisan
effort to address the problem with
Pentagon falling victim to price gouging
from defense contractors so now I want
you to think about the shy Assad who is
a former executive VP and chief contract
negotiator at Raytheon and defense
Department's most senior and awarded
contract negotiator said the following
he said the roots of the problem can be
traced to 1993 when the Pentagon looking
to reduce costs urge defense companies
to merge and 51 major contractors
Consolidated to five giants Lockheed
Martin Raytheon General Dynamics
Northrop Grumman and Boeing that could
have been the dumbest thing they could
have done why because you have fifth 51
companies competing for number so uni
taxpayers can get the best rate now
they're saying nope there's only five
companies you can go through and those
five kind of said well listen guys we
can compete as much as we want but we're
kind of on the same team as well because
there's no other companies we got
everybody thank you to the government
wink wink we're good to go here's one
thing to keep in mind the Pentagon
overpays for almost everything radar
missiles helicopters planes submarines
everything down to the nuts and bolts
matter of fact NASA once paid ten
thousand dollars for an oil pressure
switch that only costs 328 dollars and
in the competitive environment before
the company's Consolidated a shoulder
fire stinger missile that costs only
twenty five thousand dollars in 1991
with Raytheon now being the sole
supplier of that missile it now costs
more than four hundred thousand dollars
to replace each missile sent to Ukraine
guess what it's a beautiful place for
these guys to be you got a monopoly
you're the only person that can sell it
what a beautiful place to be I got no
six seven other people to compete
against no guess what what used to be
twenty five thousand dollars uh what do
you think should settle for Johnny I
think 400 Grand is 400 Grand pay you
ain't got nowhere else to go you got to
come through me so in a 60-minute
interview Bill Whitaker is interviewing
General bogdon who's a three-star
Lieutenant General with the Air Force
and Bill Whitaker is talking about
what's wrong with profits being made
there is nothing wrong with profit this
is America this is our system Chris says
no there isn't but taking to an extreme
industry may not make the best decisions
in the best interest of the government
and he continued to say we've only begun
to feel the full impact in 2012 he was
tapped to take the reins of the troubled
F-35 Joint Strike Fighter program it was
seven years behind schedule and 90
billion dollars over the original
estimate but bhag then told us the
biggest costs are yet to come for
support and maintenance which could end
up costing taxpayers ready
1.3 trillion dollars that's maintenance
1.3 trillion dollars you're paying for
it he continues says we won't be buying
too many F-35 planes as we thought
because it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense to buy airplanes more airplanes
when you can't even afford the ones that
you currently have and this continues by
according to 60 Minutes contractors
overcharge the dod on almost everything
the military buys each year almost half
of the pentagon's budget for the
upcoming fiscal year will go to defense
contract to some contractors withhold
pricing information from the defense
department Boeing refused to share cost
information for nearly 11 000 items
between October of 2020 and September of
2021 according to an annual DOD report
to Congress on pricing data that same
report found trans dime a subcontractor
was responsible for 275 data denials
Japan what's the big deal here's what
the big deal is you know how Raytheon
Northrop Grumman you know how all these
guys Boeing view the Department of
Defense here's how to view them it's
like when my wife when she goes to the
mechanic shop with the car and they see
my wife where's the husband husband's
not here I'm having a problem with this
oh it's going to cost us seventy two
hundred dollars it could have been 300
like my wife's gonna call me and say
babe it's going to cost seven seventy
two hundred dollars did not go back and
say bro what is what is this 72 oh well
you know we can probably do for 600 what
happened all of a sudden you see how
somebody else goes they're like oh over
charge them don't worry about it they
don't check it anyway it's not their
money keep charging them that's kind of
the best analogy to give you to tell you
how Raytheon Northrop Grumman views
Department of Defense so now let's look
at U.S government spending when you look
at U.S government spending what
percentage goes where here's a top
spending by category in agency 21 it
goes to Social Security 14 help 13
Medicare 13 income security 13 National
Defense and roughly 50 percent of that
entire budget goes straight to
contractor so imagine 900 billion
dollars fifty percent 450 go straight to
the contractors so you may say well Pat
that 900 billion how do we compare to
other countries here's what U.S compares
to other countries when it comes down to
our budget ready United States spends
more on defense than the next 10
countries combined that's China Russia
India Saudi Arabia UK Germany France
South Korea Japan Ukraine combined
that's how much we spent and who makes
money look at the top 10 companies how
much they get from us this is just the
contract that we have right now with
these guys Lockheed Martin 45 point six
billion dollars that's the obligation we
have to them Raytheon 25.7 General
Dynamics 22 billion Pfizer 16.6 Boeing
14.4 Northrop Grumman Corporation 13.81
Humana 7 billion H2 Corps six and a half
billion L3 headers Technologies six and
a half billion BAE Systems PLC 5 billion
dollars so again if you're a
pro-militator like I am you may say
about Pat what's wrong with that this is
why America is so safe this is why
nobody attacks us this is why we're okay
I'm with you there but let's look at how
the stocks of some of these companies
have done compared to S P 500 since 2000
20 something years let's see how they do
if you look at the chart here look all
the way at the bottom you see that navy
blue color that says 96.15 that's how S
P 500 has done from 2000 till today
General Dynamics the stock has gone up
548 percent Raytheon 574 Boeing 736
percent Northrop Grumman 1160 and last
but not least all the way at the the top
Lockheed Martin fifteen hundred and ten
percent return on investment so when I
saw this I said Okay I want to see who
has the most shares in these companies
and what their incentives would be so
let's take a look to see if there's any
trend on what companies invest the most
in these companies all right so if you
look at the top 10 shareholders of
Raytheon all the way at the top State
Street then it's who Vanguard then it's
who BlackRock surprised all three are
the ESG group so think about it they
even had their hands in military so
these guys are running our military you
think they want more war you think they
want more conflict do you think they
want a president that's a president of
peace with nowhere going on or do you
think they want a president that creates
more Havoc proxy wars because there's
more contracts for these guys to make
money I'm not speculating I'm simply
asking an innocent question let's look
at Boeing number one shareholder
Vanguard Dennis Newport Dennis BlackRock
then at State Street again let's look at
Lockheed State Street at the top then
Vanguard then guess what BlackRock let's
look get General Dynamics you got
Longview Vanguard Newport Wellington
BlackRock Capital research State Street
a little bit concerning to see what
these guys are investing I mean what do
you think these guys want to do you
think they want their stock to do good
or bad they're like yeah let's get let's
do better remember better ingredients
better Pizza Papa John more Wars more
people dying defense contractors come on
guys let's create more Wars and low-key
let's talk about peace but we need Wars
because we're going to make more money
pure speculation not telling you that's
what's happening I'm just saying it's a
good thing to speculate now watch this
we look at how many contracts are
getting somebody else to outbid them and
how many of them have no competition 10
years ago in 2012 57 percent of
contracts negotiation had somebody that
was shopping them as a second
opportunity today that's down to 52
percent what does this mean Mr Pat
that's not that big of a deal okay I
understand but you know what it means
whenever there's fewer and fewer and
fewer competition guess who's winning
you're sitting there saying look guys
you have us on somebody else who you
want to go with and we're both on the
same team you know how they you're a lot
of times people say well you know it's
no such thing as Republicans and
Democrats they're both on the same team
no The Establishment is on the same team
this is a form of an establishment
within the defense Contracting industry
we're part of the same thing guys you're
going to give me the same price let's
just do the same thing cool who are you
going to go with we'll go with you we'll
go with you good we're good to go
everybody made their money final
thoughts so now you may say Pat you
don't sound like a capitalist I'm a
capitalist no no you do not sound like a
capitalist what's wrong with these guys
making money I totally get it there's
many ways to make money one thing I
don't want to do to make money is I
don't want to see more Wars with people
dying for you to make more money I've
actually lived through a war as a kid so
when I watch a movie and in the movie I
hear the whistling sound I have an
immediate reaction maybe you watch a
whistling Sun you're like oh it's just a
movie to me a whistling sound goes back
to me being six years old living in Iran
five second pause you don't hear
anything in a boom next one comes boom
what's telling you is the bomb is
getting closer to you and you actually
knew when the plane flew over and then
you looked at your mom and your dad and
you're crying and you're hoping it left
us and they say it's okay we're not
going to get bombed that brings back
certain experiences as a kid right I
don't want to see people dying and
there's a lot of innocent people going
through this now on the capitalism side
how do we correct this we need more
companies can we tell these guys to
break apart no why not don't we have a
monopoly law yeah Monopoly law if you
Google it right it'll say 50 but isn't
that the law let's enforce it if they
really wanted to enforce the Monopoly
law iPhone right now you know what the
number is at Google right now what
percentage of market share does iPhone
own in America you know what the number
is 58 how come no one's called an iPhone
and Apple and saying hey you got a
monopoly have you heard a story of
anybody approaching apple right now to
say you got a monopoly with phones
what's another competitor what do you
own what are you watching this on right
now an iPhone you know what the chances
are maybe a Droid and maybe all your
friends are saying stop texting me with
a Droid and a group text you're green
you need to be blue and you'll be
enforced to change to iPhone because
you're green you know what I'm talking
about you're like well I'm not going to
switch totally fine guess what apple has
a monopoly no one's doing anything about
it my concern is we need more phone
companies more contractors for people to
compete with the only thing I can think
about on how we can fix this is the
founder mentality let me explain to what
I mean by this so why do these guys not
care why do the employees at Department
defense not care about the fact that I'm
paying ten thousand dollars for a 300
thing here's why the individual I
promoted to be the president of my
company the insurance company is a girl
named morale morale kishis she was my
banker at Chase years ago at WAMU I
hired her she's been with me for 13
years I kept telling her I said the day
you treat the company's money like your
own is the day you're ready to be a
c-suite executive and I kept saying this
over and over and over again which means
some guys are like how much is it going
to cost oh it's fine ten thousand
dollars fine it's like how much ten
thousand dollars I got a couple other
options this guy quoted 7 200 this guy
quoted sixty eight hundred dollars for
the same exact thing and it would say oh
well you know let me let me get back to
give us 30 minutes to come back we can
do for sixty seven hundred dollars Bingo
saved the company thirty three hundred
dollars she's got founder mentality
versus some other people are like oh
just paid a ten Grand who cares it's not
our money anyways the company we can
afford it no you just cost us thirty
three hundred dollars so how many of
these employees work in our department
and defense have the founders mindset
none of them why it's not their money
it's your money they're spending so we
have to figure out a way to change the
comp plan on the way these guys are
negotiating on your behalf it's our
country it's our money there's got to be
accountability if there isn't any
accountability with margins next to it
prices next to it Congress can tell
every one of these companies if you
don't give us a price point on your
products up front we ain't buying from
you and they can figure right away to
cause these guys to give actual prices
to not bully you the taxpayer that's one
of the only ways I see us being able to
hold these guys accountable all right so
if you got value out of this video give
it a thumbs up subscribe to the channel
if you got a solution on how you would
fix this comment if you enjoyed this
video I got another video I want you to
watch about how the military is going to
walk if you've not yet seen that click
here to watch that clip take everybody
bye-bye bye-bye
foreign
[Music]